[Music]
Gregg Alba here John Humphrey
we're gonna watch black stop black stop
blacktop freestyles on flex black styles
Freeth on hashtag freestyle 0 87 you see
one of our top of war tears on our
patreon we gotta get it on is whatever
video you request we must definitely do
put up on YouTube and do our absolute
best and today comes from Stuart George
who is a topper war tier patreon sending
us checks that are not forged he he
gorgeous whatever I'm not the rapper you
know you are no black black styles free
thought it like thought from the roots
if I'm not mistaken so this should be
interesting at a patron John does music
video reactions quite often and when
it's rap sometimes you join me
sometimes I join you you know it to be
true I like to drink my Mountain Dew
who's your favorite Mortal Kombat
character King comma lu that's not the
first loop king reference i've heard my
rap song either so really
yeah yeah nine inches
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I made the 21 we're money down solely
what sound
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ten minutes Jesus Christ ten minutes of
a one-take apparently Wow take no breath
like Oh breather Jesus Christ like I
said they're sane I kept thinking is at
least gonna like because I'm gonna take
yeah damn that was nuts yeah halfway
through I was like wait a minute
when is he breathing and then I started
to pay attention just to see when I
could pick up the times where he's
actually drawing breath and like is so
impressive cuz he must be so used to
this that it's gotta be second nature
now just to drawing a breath between the
syllables whereas like when you're prep
it in like a hip-hop song for karaoke
you're like where's my breath go you
have that energy and passion you become
breathless man that was amazing like
that was that was so impressive yeah I
mean Royce was impressive too but like
holy [ __ ] like that was just a block
mm-hmm wall the wall right here me
pulled in after like a lot of times
these are super impressive and you start
to finally really pick up on what
they're saying or their commentary I
love that even wanted to like his past
and I like we can't dealing with his mom
and the substance abuse and all these
things and then going into like who he
turned into and who he is now now just
walking talking affirmation [ __ ] this is
crazy
who's the guy who hosts this fun mr.
flex yeah man I love his reactions I
don't want him to start his own reaction
channel or else I just want to find a
way they had so that he can just kind of
be around me so that when I do something
particular all right like nothing's got
to feel better than having him in the
corner being like look at this like you
know like III don't know if black not
was noticing that but if it was me on
the mic I would just be like thank you
thank you
vibe I know the roots are huge and
everything and I've actually seen his
free stop bits when Jimmy Fallon
sometimes has a rapper freestyling they
have him go back and forth yeah like
they pick a word and then they have to
like make a freestyle out of it but I
didn't realize just how crazy this guy's
vocabulary is man like this is a wide
range of vocabulary not just the end
syllable rhyme just everything in
between - man oh yeah I mean he's deuce
is an artist right is an artist yeah I
mean he's doing like polyrhythmic stuff
was like these word choices and like
yeah forming these really intricate so
you'll have a rhyme at the end of a
stands or a bar or whatever but you'll
have like Ryan's inside of it you know
which yeah man like the vocabulary the
placement and everything and it's it's
like it's crazy to think that this is
off the dome ostensively because yeah
it's so composed you know he's got to
put in so much time just practicing and
playing around and honing his skills cuz
yeah just like it's a solid block of
just a stream of consciousness that has
such a defined shape and and series of
themes and sentiments like holy [ __ ]
that was an epic this is what I'm gonna
listen to over and over and over I just
love how it was one take man this is
inspired like like I'm sitting here
going like man I want to learn like this
is hand i watch somebody like really
really demolish a microphone that way
I'm like wow I wish I could do I feel
like he's underrated in a lot of ways
man oh yeah he should be more in the
talk in the public sphere yeah I mean
like I see him not collab with Royce or
something like that have you bomb I
wonder if they have I mean you know like
if you're hip-hop hat I gotta imagine
you definitely know who Black Thought is
but like in the more mainstream I feel
like the biggest presence of the roots
is quest because he's just like the poet
this guy yeah he's like a poet and rap
format it's like when you hear stuff
like this you go this is like great rap
music right here you know yeah
rap has become a lot more respected over
the years but you know there was that
time there was that time where it was
disregarded as just drug music to
provoke [ __ ] this is like this is
more than just being hard as more as
being tough well and it has those
elements but in a way that feels wholly
authentic and part of a wedding just a
picture yeah yeah I love this this is
great
Stewart's George they should go to
Stewart George's channel guys where's it
where's Jenna put his link in there he
did a reaction to Eminem's not a like
song whoo that John and I watched and
look we're gonna watch it again okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
your neck movements manner are just so
on point like your neck game is strong
he's trying to figure out like what the
next move for his own channel is I want
that I want more of that for any song
just do that exactly you could just even
just use that same video to put
different different music filtered if
you want to know what to do with your
channel do that and I guarantee you
it'll be a major hit channel so now
every month I'm just going to expect a
mind-blowing freestyle request from you
just do what your heart tells you do
what your heart tells you follow your
heart man so you're doing this thing
right now where you read off youtube
comments which is one of your ideas that
you wanted us to do tell you what let's
read one comment let's read the top
what's the top of the top here top
comment is I hope
lost all respect for Black Thought how
could you take job how could the man do
that to an innocent microphone what did
that microphone at and what about all
the other rappers that wanted a chance
to shine he ruined it for everyone who
wants to step to the mic after what he
just did Funk Flex is gonna have a lot
of rappers calling in sick after now
that is worth the 6 point 6 K likes
that's a good hey you're right you know
what instead of reacting and giving our
own thoughts let's react and then react
to comments
yeah dude comment really then then
everybody wait for the reaction chance
yeah as sex is gonna devolve really fast
into us going alright guys well you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell you check us out
patreon subscribe to hot 97 as soon as
you can please